d'ailleurs au quotidien avec notre
équipe du lundi au vendredi même les
jours fériés et il y en a beaucoup au
mois de mai c'est peut-être aussi
l'occasion pourquoi pas d'occuper nos
enfants et avec les grands parents bien
souvent parce que ça peut servir
dans ces cas là eh bien on prend la
sélection livres pour les enfants et
tiphaine vous nous avez trouvé quelques
sélections importante avec justement ces
figures incontournables dans la vie des
enfants
les grands parents oui parce que vous le
savez pas ce qu'elle est je suis sûr que
vous aussi vous avez eu une grand mère
ou un grand père adoré comme une momie
plein de petites choses indispensables
ou anodine et c'est le cas de ce petit
garçon justement du livre mon pépé
d'emilie chazerand et nicolas dufau aux
éditions gautier languereau alors ce pp
là il lui a appris à siffler avec des
feuilles à faire des ricochets à boire
avec sa main vous savez dit jusque là
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire quand on est
petit et le jour on y arrive c'est
merveilleux et donc ce petit garçon
adore son pépé et un jour il se rend
compte que son pépé ne sait pas lire
incroyable son pépé qui sait tout faire
ne sait pas lire alors et se dit eh bien
moi je vais lui apprendre
je vais lui apprendre parce que moi
j'adore lire et je vais lui faire
partager ça alors ce livre est très beau
moi je l' ai adoré et je pense que les
enfants aussi vont l'aimer parce que les
enfants vous le savez adore en fait
faire partager toutes les nouveautés et
tout ce qu'ils savent à leurs grands
parents y compris à leurs arrière grands
parents
donc je pense que c'est un très joli
cadeau à faire aux enfants de la barre
soit des grands parents soient des
arrière grands parents
voilà j'aime dans ce livre là de ce ppp
que son pépé lui avait appris à attraper
les chats par la peau du cou et oui nous
permet maintenant il ya un vétérinaire
qui est là et vous en avait un dans les
bras ça s'est bien rattrapé rachat par
le poids du coup jean matthieu ricard
ça permet effectivement de les prendre
il faut prendre une grosse poignée pour
pas passé mais la maman maman ocean
quand elle prend ses bébés les prend par
la peau du cou pour les emmener en
sécurité et c est ça apaise ya des
hitmen des clips exprès pour les tenir
l'un pendant qu'on puisse d'accord c'est
autre chose
martyriser son chaque de le prendre dès
maintenant on prend une grosse position
pince ça finit par être douloureux si
haut pour une grosse poignée
d'où leur part fait allez maintenant on
va prendre à lui c'est un super ppc
super pp c'est vrai pour apprendre à
lire à 70 ans il faut quand même
beaucoup de volonté c'est pas forcément
facile pour apprendre les cascades à 80
aussi et pourtant vous nous avez trouvé
quelque chose de sympathique
oui alors mamie cascade en fait elle la
prend pas les cascades figurez vous que
c'est une ancienne cascadeuse d'ailleurs
son nom de scène c'était jacky quand
même ça c'est pas rien et alors un jour
figurez vous qu'elle elle commence à
sentir son corps faiblir voilà elle a
mal aux chevilles
elle se dit bon c'est fini pour moi je
vais en finir je vais mettre fin à mes
jours voilà autant prendre des décisions
radicales mais elle reçoit un coup de
fil d'un réalisateur qui lui propose de
tourner dans un film et de reprendre ses
anciennes cascade
alors là elle se dit chiche j'ai cinq
mois pour me préparer je vais tourner
dans ce film quitte à finir en beauté
c'est le point de départ de ce livre de
paul ivoire qui est bourguignon et qui
est publié aux éditions anne carrière
alors je vous en parle ça peut paraître
un petit peu lugubre comme ça à une
mamie qui veut mettre fin à ses jours
mais pas du tout c'est un livre
passionnant parce que déjà une mamie
cascadeuse moi j'en ai pas eu
mais celle-ci allait elle est géniale ça
me rappelle poupette vous savez dans la
boum denise grey vous vous rappelez
était à fond avec sa ses morceaux est un
peu sans du coup voilà il ya plein de
personnages secondaires qui sont tous en
caux en couleurs des grands timides un
gang de motards
alors évidemment il ya des cascades d'un
livre ça ferait un film épatant
je vous conseille ce livre c'est
émouvant c'est drôle
voilà je pense que ça plaira aux ados on
va dire à partir de 13 ans 14 ans va
l'ajout de conseil
l'épi cocorico pour l'ivoire est bon
l'union vous l'avez dit oui il est bon
on est super fiers parce que voilà il
est connu pour la littérature jeunesse
au départ alors ce livre là il n'est pas
classé littérature jeunesse mais moi je
le conseille voilà de la littérature
jeunesse parce qu'il ya des cascades des
rebondissements et une histoire d'amour
évidemment et une couverture top parce
que voilà on pourrait se dire il se
moque pas du tout c'est très rigolo en
réaction essentielle des tanins cette
mamie l'ain
une super mamie aller une grand-mère
adorée peut-être aussi une grand mère
adoptive
mais oui évidemment vous savez parfois
c'est la voisine c'est la mamie qu'à
aider à élever la maman voilà et dans ce
livre là la fille qui avait bu la lune
de kelly bar nîmes qui est aussi édité
par à une carrière
et bien c'est la grand-mère de la petite
luna alors la petite luna elle a été
abandonnée parce que dans ce monde
imaginaire
on abandonne un enfant chaque année à la
méchante sorcière
alors on ne sait pas si elles existent
vous allez découvrir puisque c'est un
livre il ya des sorcières des dragons de
la magie c'est merveilleux et donc on
découvre cette relation entre luna et sa
grand mère adoptive
exane c'est vraiment un très joli lire
qu'il plaira à tous les fans de magie
c'est épique c'est un roman initiatique
je vous le conseille
c'est merveilleux et c'est même
philosophique un petit peu comme tous
les livres de fantasy évidemment c'est
super on va terminer rapidement avec un
livre aussi sympa avec des grands
parents qui sont aussi assez
exceptionnel racontez moi alors elle est
évidemment elle s'appelle madeleine et à
leur aile à 95 ans et elle ne veut pas
quitter sa maison qui est au bord d'une
falaise en normandie est là vous pouvez
l'imaginer c'est une maison juchée au
bord de la falaise et la mer la
grignotte cette falaise et madeleine à
la 95 ans est hors de question qu'elle
quitte la maison pour aller en maison de
retraite
vous voyez la maison là vous voyez la
falaise qui commença à tomber et
madeleine pourquoi elle veut pas quitter
bat déjà c'est parce qu'elle voit pas le
danger parce qu'elle est aveugle de
naissance donc pour elle ce danger là
bas il n'existe pas et puis en plus bas
elle elle veut mourir dans sa maison
elle n'a pas d'autre
d'autres voient la volonté est donc tout
le village se met à la convaincre alors
cette bande dessinée s'appelle jamais de
duhamel publié chez grand temps que je
vous la conseille et cette fois il vient
c'est une grand mère bas adopté par un
village quoi un super nom connaissez je
suis mais oui bien sûr non non vous a
adopté un veau venir évidemment pour
d'autres aventures à merci
tfn pour cette sélection livre